if you think there's not a lot of sugar
daddies out there you're wrong I'd spent
certainly six figures across five years
and I match with these two girls who
claim to be sisters and you guys like
have sex with each other and she's like
well if we go to your room you could
watch and find out yeah man I guess
that's what we're doing
and sure enough they're like going down
on each other the oldest girl does all
the Talking she's on top of me and she
looks down at me and she goes I know who
you are and I'm like what because I've
been blackmailed by the very first girl
in metal seeking and so I'm like are we
gonna have a problem here she's like no
no nothing like that I'm a fan me and my
sister collect YouTubers and I said You
what she goes yeah yeah we've
had sex with a lot of YouTubers that's
why we match with you you're not
normally our type I said what other
YouTubers have you met and she said I
was in a Logan Paul video
and I said the you were did you
Logan Paul and she said no of
course not the same way I didn't just
boogie2988 and then she packed her
and left the true Geordie podcast